[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum thank you for being
with me
being with me for you for your week your
week's very busy
and uh i i thank you for listening to
this podcast you have a lot of choices
and you're choosing to be with me you're
choosing to be with me and ryan's here
i'm here don't forget ryan if you don't
want to be with me you could be with
ryan i'm choosing to be with you
thank you for choosing to be with me
choosing to be with michael yeah and
he's still got the mustache some people
have commented on the mustache they like
it i forgot i like the mustache i forgot
it was still there i think i like the
mustache when you have some scruff with
it yeah it's a little less um
boring porny porny yeah porny porny yeah
that's true uh we'll get to the guest in
in a second but uh i'm just going to let
you know that i'm going to be in st
louis may 13th with tom welling we're
going to do a smallville nights on a
friday night so look at that st louis
khan uh you could uh we're going to post
something uh here soon so may 13th that
weekend in st louis i'll be in liverpool
may 21st or that weekend around there uh
june 10th illinois metropolis con in
metropolis illinois june 17th for two
weeks australia perth
and sydney uh july 28th raleigh
and august 12th boston
uh so make sure you come see me please
come see me
uh also the inside of you online store
is open if you want to get any cool
merch
smallville stuff there's a small script
signed lunch boxes
inside you tumblers tons of cool stuff
so go to the inside of you online store
and also if you want any sunspin merch
or you want to zoom me uh you could zoom
me on sunspin.com
and there are zooms there you can book
the band i'm on cameo you know it's all
that stuff
um and what are our handles if you want
to follow us if this is your first time
listening i hope you'll you'll join us
at inside if you pause on twitter
insideablepodcast on instagram and
facebook oh and that
is how you can find it that's it it's
easy also if you want to join patreon
join me
support the podcast we need you go to
patreon.com inside of you that's
p-a-t-r-e-o-n
patreon.com inside of you and uh you
know however you want to support the
podcast there's a lot of cool stuff on
there there's tears i send merch i'll
send you a message after you join we
could use your help so thank you
this week's guest mark paul gossler i
i've been wanting to get him on the
podcast for a while he's fantastic he's
such a great guy you've seen him in
everything um
mixtish uh the passage he's been on tons
of shows
um in movies
you know him a lot by saved by the bell
um
zack morris
so i finally got him on the podcast and
he was very uh open and uh gave me a lot
of good stuff gave us a lot of good
stuff
so um so without further ado let's get
inside of mark paul gossler it's my
point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
wait a minute
we're starting this podcast off with you
have a bad memory
i really do
how have you done all these shows all
these
shows that require you learning a lot of
dialogue and your memory isn't good
because i always say the same thing like
i can't remember should i have to go
over [ __ ] a million times before i get
it right
i have a flash memory
and i can remember things like if you
told me if you give me a piece of paper
with a monologue on it i could probably
get it in about five minutes
no problem
but
retaining it it goes out
when i walk out the door it's gone
and i just it's like a um i was
listening to howard stern yesterday and
he was saying like his memory is like a
fishbowl like he goes to the other side
of the fishbowl and it's a new
experience that's how i am kind of i
guess i live in the moment
which is scary because
a lot of great things have happened to
me and i don't remember a lot of it and
i feel bad for the people that
experienced it with me for instance my
wife right
she'll say do you remember this i'm like
i don't but it doesn't mean i don't love
you and i it doesn't mean that i didn't
have a great time doing it just my brain
doesn't work that way
wow so what give me an example of
something you might not remember maybe
going to
uh you know the botanical gardens
together something that was really nice
and sweet and it was like five years ago
you won't really be able to retain that
or you you kind of
it's vague
very vague i'd say vague um
there's certain yeah i mean again
how how would i remember these things
because i can't ever you know how can i
remember those experiences and give you
an example if i can't remember them
this was the whole reason that i started
the podcast uh my podcast
was because i don't remember
my experience on save by the bell
to a certain degree and the degree of
that was
i don't remember the work of it
and i don't remember the day-to-day of
it but i remember little experiences
here and there when we'd go offset when
we'd go to epidemics
and we hang out with
other
child actors when we go
on location of palm springs or hawaii or
things like that you remember little
bits and pieces like that um but just
the other day i mean tiffany um
uh if people don't know played kelly uh
she was talking to me and she was
remember when i got my license and i
drove up to you and i got in an accident
with you in the car and i go you did
i have no recollection and that was a
big thing for her and she says yeah you
helped me like
work through it and i have no i have no
idea what she's talking about it's as if
i'm talking to a stranger that is
unbelievable how you just don't remem i
mean i remember [ __ ] but like i
i'm not one who could learn a monologue
in five minutes i'll take a week to
learn it
and then i'll know it inside out and i
can it kind of stays with me for a
little while but i think i'd rather have
your memory in a sense that you could
just pick up something do it and then i
don't know i guess there's a bad bad
side to both
yeah i agree i mean you remember when
your kids were born right
yes
yeah
yeah i have i have four of them so i you
know i have i have four chances to
remember but yes i remember i remember
their burns where did you and i meet you
think the first time this you're never
going to get that i i think didn't you
play hockey
i i used to play hockey um
you know it's funny i was i was trying
to remember if this
story is true or not because it lives in
my head so i have no one to ask
but when i
got nypd blue i had just gotten off of
a wb show
and smallville was on cw right mm-hmm wb
and then because then went to cw right
right
and and um
because what wasn't it like wb and upn
and then they all
merged into like the cw or something
like that
i know that warner brothers wb became cw
i don't know if upn did did they ryan
i don't know i don't know [ __ ] you're
asking the wrong person
well the story was is that i was on a wb
show and it was pilot season and i
actually went in to go read for
uh a stephen bachchan pilot called
philly with kim delaney and before i
walked in
um
they had already offered it to tom
everett scott who i did a movie with a
few years
prior
and i said [ __ ] it i'm going i'm still
going in i want to go in and i want to
get this role i really like the role and
i think i can reverse their offer
um which you know it doesn't happen in
this business um but i went in and it
was the first time i met stephen at the
end of it he says you're really good and
i'd like to work with you and i thought
oh you know he's just being nice
and uh he goes i know it's pilot season
but keep me up to date if you get if you
get something
let me know
and i thought that's an interesting
thing so we tried with my management at
the time uh we tried to get anything we
possibly could and small bill came
around and i looked at it and i'm not
right for this this isn't my jam i i i'm
not a
i don't know much about the superhero
world i didn't grow up with it um i
didn't quite understand the character
but i remember going in for small build
and really [ __ ] the bed on that
interview but it was just so that i
could possibly get
something in pilot season so that i
could go back to stephen bochko and
bring it to him uh and that was that i
think that i don't know if you and i met
while we were reading or if you were
offered that no i i read i read for that
uh it was one of those things where they
said you know 700 guys
came in i'm like what the what are they
[ __ ] doing wrong why don't you tell
me what they're doing wrong that was the
kind of thing did you so you read for it
i did read for it and i don't know you
are right for the part you were i think
you were right for that i mean no not
then not then not nothing i was
not then i was you know i was a very
immature
28 year old i think at the time and i
wasn't right then um it took me a while
to to blossom as they say michael
um but uh after that i got uh
i actually didn't need to get anything
in that pilot season because stephen
bichko came and offered me a role on
nypd blue to replace rick schroeder
wow it all worked out how hard was it by
the way working on a series like nypd
blue because it was really popular and
there's i mean it's pretty intense right
yeah i'm glad i i'm glad we're not doing
it now i'm glad i'm not like walking
onto a show that like that now because
with all social media and everyone has
an opinion and you can read about
everyone's opinions
back then uh early 2000 there was one
guy with a blog
uh steppenwall um alan steppenwald who
you know still writes and critiques
stuff and he had a fan page and i just
remember reading that i was going to
[ __ ] the bed i was gonna bring the
franchise down
uh i was horrible and by the way i
thought they were right like i was
i was literally
um
uh i was literally uh
thinking the same thing like i'm a
california kid i'm playing a new york
detective
alongside dennis franz who is arguably
the best
um
actor of that generation uh you know he
had been nominated nine times for an
emmy uh through the course of that uh
12-year run and i'm coming in as
as this kid who i i didn't feel i proved
myself i didn't read for the role so
stephen bosco
basically hired me off of an audition
that i did for another role
um
but i did you know i'm sure you've done
things where you've been offered things
and you doubt yourself you're like i
do they do they really think i can do
this character can i do that can i do i
think i can do this character yeah
and you know what's scarier is when you
actually get an offer you'd almost
rather audition because they see you
auditioning they're like yes that's what
you're doing is right because when you
go get an offer and you go on set and
you start doing something like no
yeah what do you i don't know what the
[ __ ] to do you just gave me an offer
what am i then you feel kind of lost
yeah that's terrifying
i'm sure you and i are the same way like
i have no problem going into an audition
and being rejected right not getting it
oh i've done this
whatever i mean it happens to all of us
right we go in we give our best we're
not the guy maybe it's a look maybe it's
our read maybe it's the casting director
the producer is having a bad day
whatever it is but the one thing that i
would think
hurts the most is being fired off of
something getting something being on a
set being around your peers and then
going yeah you know what this isn't what
we wanted and then being fired that have
you been fired have you been fired
uh
the only one that i remember being fired
for was a commercial i believe it was
for like whammo or something like that
and i got fired off the commercial my my
consolation prize was like a box full of
toys
but uh you'll like this um i was
replaced by paul walker
who at the time like paul and i would
we're the two blondes
in the uh in the industry at that time
you know we were probably eight or nine
at the time and we were the
the guys that would do all the
commercials if you needed a blonde kid
it was either paul walker mark paul wow
you know i remember i remember getting
fired
uh it was only the one time i got fired
but they they made me the offer it was
uh a will ferrell and uh mckay
show oh
big top show and they just made me an
offer and i had a meeting and they made
me an offer and i went in and the whole
time they're like you're killing it
we're watching dailies the director's
coming up to me every day oh my god
you're killing it you're killing it
you're killing it we ended up having a
screening at my house at the show with
the cast and everybody and then two
weeks later
they called me the producer in tears and
said
well the good news is i mean they want
to pick us up for five episodes but we
have to let you go they want to replace
your character they think your
character's too dark and says the wrong
[ __ ] and
and i was like what we just screened
this at my house and
every day you're telling me how great i
am and it just shows you how it all is
[ __ ] you just
you never know when it's gonna happen
and i was just like holy [ __ ] they just
let me go i've never been let go and it
just
it is crushing but then i remember
sitting in my office and kind of looking
outside going all right you're alive
breathe breathe you got a dog here i
love your dog you love your dog you got
a house you're lucky to be here i
started to you know these affirmations
you reaffirming that you know hey you
know you're okay you're gonna be okay
but it was it was it was tough
to be let go especially off like your
heroes
will ferrell
and like you know wow i'm gonna be
really working with will ferrell it's
his show
and look the show never made it to air
uh they never even shot those five
episodes but still that feeling i had
was like here was my chance you know
adam mckay wrote wrote me an email hey
it was nothing you did i'd love to work
with you in the future of course that
never happens how many times did you
hear that besides botchco telling you i
want to work with you and it actually
happens it almost never happened before
with you
no the only guy that's been that way
with for me has been bochko because i
did nypd blue and then he went and
jumped to commander in chief
um
a year after we wrapped nypd blue and
then he did a show called raising the
bar and he hired me for that as well um
and then years later he actually gave me
my second directing gig on one of his
shows called murder in the first
um but he always thought of me he always
he was over he was he was really good to
me it was like a father figure he was
the first guy i went to when i uh
uh
when i got a divorce and i needed a
place to stay i i went to you know his
his uh
palace in the um in the palisades and
said hey can i uh
can i rent a room for a little bit he
goes what'd you do
[ __ ] happens man and he he was like he
was like a great father he um
it was he he always gave it to me
straight i remember sitting in his
kitchen it was late because you know
these things happen out of nowhere and
uh
he he just said uh what are your plans i
said i'm gonna try to make this work
and he just said don't that's okay let
it go he's like he got a good run out of
it yeah yeah he gave it to me straight
man just said uh just just let it go and
he was right
he was right he was right yeah yeah
inside of you is brought to you by
faraday i
wanted these guys as a sponsor i have
spent so much money
buying their product because i've never
felt shirts that feel this way
faraday makes
delicious clothing
uh i don't know what else to tell you
how many people have gone what material
is that it feels really nice get your
hands off me
um
it's a great product everyone is talking
about fake spring and how difficult it
is to dress around this time but that's
because it is it can be so difficult to
find the right outfit in the spring when
every day is different and the weather
can change at the drop of a hat and
luckily for all of us faridy
makes it way easier they make the
perfect clothes for all seasons ryan
what is ferrity
verity is a family-run brand making high
quality timeless clothing with modern
design and functionality it's that kind
of effortless style you want every time
you go digging in your closet that set
that shirt that dress that feels like
you've had them for years right
this is what we want we want something
that feels like we've worn it and that's
what faraday is maybe it's a gorgeous
print and it looks like it might be
vintage but it fits so well that it
feels like it was made just yesterday
just for you
guys
that's verity and faraday's so confident
the quality of their stuff they have a
lifetime guarantee of quality they'll
replace or fix your clothes forever
forever no matter what talk about making
it easier to get dressed and right now
faraday is giving all inside of you
listeners
20 off that's 20
off and they have a guarantee that
they'll replace or fix your clothes
forever i don't know how you guys don't
buy it i love this company head to
ferrity brand.com that's f a h e r t y
brand dot com and use the code inside of
you at checkout and snag twenty percent
off all your new spring staples that's
code inside of you at farady a
f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand
dot-com for 20
off my good friends at ferrity inside of
you is brought to you by shopify if
you've never used shopify
i know how to do it i use shopify
from my inside of you podcast
they have made it so easy for me to
keep track of products keep track of
what products are doing well
inventory
it's all at the click of a button and so
simple
shopify has really changed my life in a
lot of ways
things need to be easy for me to use
them do you understand ryan
i think it's it's
simple i like things simplistic shopify
gives entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big business
so upstarts startups and established
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed scaling
your business is a journey of endless
possibility and believe me this podcast
started selling a few products and we
weren't doing that great and but
shopify made it so easy for people to
get merch and things like that
they set up the whole shipping thing so
you just print out the label here's
their address it just prints it out you
really don't do a heck of a lot
today business is great my shopify
account is kicking ass
and you know i love how shopify has the
tools and resources that make it easy
for any business to succeed from down
the street to around the globe
um and like mine shopify powers millions
of businesses from first sale to full
scale reach customers online and across
social networks with an ever growing
suite of channel integrations and apps
including facebook instagram tick tock
pinterest and more gain insights as you
grow with detailed reporting of
conversion rates profit margins and
beyond it's more than a store shopify
grows with you this is possibility
powered by shopify and if you go to
shopify right now go to shopify.com
inside all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
inside
right now shopify.com
inside
are you one of those guys that just like
you don't want you don't like to fail so
you wanted to like i got to make this
work because i'm kind of like that i
don't want things i don't want to fail i
want to how do we work this out how do
we figure this out and you're like that
yeah i think so i mean
don't you think it's our ego then i mean
yes i don't like to have i don't like to
have those check marks on my on my
resume you know it's uh
um i i feel like i i try
i like being in control of certain
things other things i'm a pisces so i
kind of go yeah certain things i like to
keep in control other things i'm like oh
[ __ ] it man i'm not worth my time right
um
and even with a divorce like i tried to
make it work to a certain point and then
once i realized it was over over
i moved on very quickly and that was it
i was done
what happens every time i'm on these
zooms i raise my hand yeah and on here
it says you're waving to me i'm like
what the [ __ ] is he doing why is there a
hand waving at me
if i could figure that out i'm literally
you know because i do these zooms for
auditions now and so you have to meet
people on zooms or whatever and i'll
raise my i'm a hand talker so i raise my
hand and then on zoom it says that i'm
raising my hand i'm like uh
trying not to
jesus uh
do you get pretty personal on your
podcast what's your podcast called
it's called zach to the future we're
taking a hiatus right now um
maybe
uh indefinitely um
we did about 50 episodes we were 50 away
from completing the run of the show
uh but basically it was every episode
we'd start from the very beginning and
uh it was me and my co-host daschle
driscoll who wrote uh zack morris's
trash
uh it's a great youtube series
where
he basically will
you know spell it out why my character
zack morris was trash
uh and he he started as a as like as
sort of a funny little
you know sketch thing for funny or die
and then it took off and he did i think
he did about four seasons of that and i
thought i'm going to do a podcast i want
to do with this guy
um he's also a writer on the reboot of
save by the bell wow and
yeah so we started this podcast because
i don't remember my experience it was
just sort of like a re-education of of
the show and i'd watch the show a few
times take notes see if i could jog any
sort of memory of the experience and we
were just talking about it be an hour of
just sort of or
you know just just bullshitting how do
you feel when you watch yourself i mean
are you an actor because some actors
hate watching themselves they loathe
their critique you hate it
even when you were young even when you
were young
tortured no i could appreciate certain
things i could appreciate certain things
but then i would bum myself out because
i then work with the new generation of
saved by the bell the new cast and i
really and i go god they were they're so
much more [ __ ] talented than i ever
was back then like
why did i
why did my career go the way it did
from that like
that to me was mediocre compared to what
these new with this new generation is
doing um so i look at it at that point
like i i say i could have done that
better i could have taken it more
serious
um
i
i try to learn from things but i don't i
learn from experiences on set i don't
learn from watching myself because then
it just becomes like a
it's already set man it's like you know
i i can't do anything about it right
it's like i'm just gonna go to sleep
grumpy is there something though that
you watched that you go you know what i
was [ __ ] good in that you know what i
appreciate my work in that there is yeah
oh yeah yeah what is that
you recall i i really liked pitch when i
was on pitch i really liked that show
um i like the passage i like some of my
work that i've done recently even on mix
dish there were some funny things that i
thought um
i kind of got right
uh and there's a lot i still you know
feel like i got wrong but um
i think it's easier to watch myself if
i'm playing a
character
if you know i'm sure it's the same for
you if you're outside of michael yeah
you're playing a complete character i
can't judge it as much because
you know it's
and i and i i guess i look back at like
saved by the belt and that was a
character that wasn't me i wasn't a cool
kid i didn't even have blonde hair i
mean i was you know i'm a
my mother's indonesian my father is
dutch
um
i i have
i come from a
mixed family and i'm playing the whitest
kid in america
you know that's true and it's and but
you think like oh i look back and say oh
that's a character but i i just some of
the choices that i made
um
with the dialogue
i i i just feel i could have done better
but did you have a lot of experience
before then with acting
not really i mean commercials and stuff
yeah so well you mean it's you can't be
that hard on yourself when you really
hadn't done anything except for
commercials
but look at these kids nowadays look at
these kids i mean just watch any show
that has a kid on it and they're amazing
like they they have such talent not only
that they're they're acting they're
saying they're dancing they're they're
just entertainers but don't you think
some of it has to do with the how it's
written
the quality of the work i mean you guys
are unsaved by the bell no offense but
it was like kind of fluff fun you know
right you don't say that michael you
know i got in trouble one time for
saying that well i remember it's a
different i agree with you i agree with
you right i totally agree with you but
12 years ago i had said
that the work i did on saved by the bell
was not breaking bad
you know basically saying that the
writing was not breaking bad well am i
right i mean anybody would say tell you
you're right
oh i gotta i i remember being on a
bicycle ride after i said that i said it
in some
you know press line or something i was
on a bicycle ride
and some
buddy from tmz
uh got my number and called me and i i
didn't even know you know back then i
just picked up the phone hello
uh would you like to um you know comment
on on your comment
say it by the bell because you know
it sounds like you're in great i'm
ungrateful for your experience and i
stress like oh [ __ ] no
no no that's not what i meant of course
that's not what you meant it's just
obvious it's like this is a a kid show
this was the
what was it the 80s the 90s it was just
kind of it was on early it wasn't
written for like a darker
we get it but like i think that if
somebody gave you a different material
at that age and you were really working
on it
things could have been different in that
in that show
maybe maybe i mean you know
maybe
um
but yeah it's that that that uh that
show is precious to some people it's
precious to a lot of people
i mean it's look at the duration i mean
how long it's lasted with the the
reunions and the
you know it's uh it's exciting i mean
it's something that you've been doing
since well i mean the last
for since when what year did you start
uh
89 89
and the last reunion of it was well
recently right
yeah we just finished up last season in
july well second season of the peacock
reboot uh we we've just finished in
september of last year and how much fun
is that do you like it
i really do um
like i said the cast is amazing it's
it's fun to work with the og cast as
well uh one of the best experiences that
i've had um
was directing last season one of the
episodes so
getting to direct the new cast the old
cast it was it was a lot of fun that's
amazing
did you know growing up in california do
you think things were it was harder for
you to grow up in california
than it would be if you were growing up
in the midwest or somewhere away from
the whole industry do you think you know
things would have been a lot different
for you
no not really because i always i always
think that i grew up outside of the
industry i grew up in the valley i grew
up in um sun valley
and uh for me
my work i always say this but my my
world was was very brown
uh sepia toned in a way um we lived in a
predominantly hispanic neighborhood
uh the other white people were sometimes
like hell's angels or bikers it's a
little rough crowd and
someone sun valley tanga right uh it was
a rough crowd back then and i used to i
used to go to a private school
sort of halfway between sun valley and
let's say
studio city
and it was a private school there and
you would
travel down laurel canyon
heading uh sort of southwest south
and you would see mulholland and you
would see the green hills and i always
like you know and then when i'd go for
auditions we'd go over mulholland we go
down into hollywood and for me that was
like
green it was success
uh it was different than where i grew up
where you know everyone had manicured
lawns and my lawn
manicured but you know next door
neighbors might be dirt
and i grew up around a lot of dirt and
so i didn't feel like i grew up uh in
the industry in hollywood in beverly
hills you didn't feel that at all
no and and you know my really good
friend brecken meyer he he kind of grew
up
in the hills and went to beverly hills
high
and uh sort of was you know hanging out
with people but when i when i went back
home
i
i hung out with
just
civilians in a way you know i didn't i
didn't hang out with people in the
industry
my parents weren't in the industry
um it was a fluke for me to get in i
just kind of got in on a whim how what
was that i'm sure you've talked about
that but what is it no it was i was four
years old and i my mom had a friend who
did like print work she was a model that
did print work and
she said oh you know
the typical thing you got your kid's
cute you should get in front of the
camera
and uh that's exactly what we did we
just sort of used her agent to get into
the business and i did print work for a
while and then did commercials and then
theatrical stuff but
i grew up in the valley i
i um
i i i
did not feel a part of
the business in any way right outsider
you're uh i look i had a dysfunctional
film i always talk about this [ __ ] in
the podcast i had dysfunction but my
parents stayed together they should have
got divorced a long [ __ ] time ago i
always said that i like i wish you would
have got no we wanted you to get through
high school my [ __ ] you you were so
[ __ ] up it was way worse for us you
should have got divorced your parents
got divorced at a young age right
well
i don't know that they legally got
divorced they were separated it was
really
odd because my dad would sometimes be
there and then sometimes he wouldn't
uh
so i never knew you know what what you
were gonna get and then i know that he
had an apartment somewhere and
i stayed there a few times but
it they were never officially divorced
uh neither one of them really wanted to
to give it up even though it was over
having noted it was over as long as i
could remember
um but yeah they they never moved on
although my dad
my dad was with the same woman
that uh kind of that he was with uh at
the time that they split until the day
he died um with the same woman she was
an angel to him
her name was angela and um you know she
just became a part of our family and um
sweet lady and she took care of my
father when he was sick uh and and but
yeah they but they never i don't think
they ever got a divorce what year did he
pass
uh last year oh yeah
not
was that just brutal for you was it
something that you were expecting or
does it just kind of happen yeah it was
something we were expecting it was we
were expecting it he uh he was in poor
health and we sort of i knew it i was
working at the time
and um i got a chance uh
to see him two weeks before he passed
away it was one of those things that we
knew he was gonna he was gonna pass so
right he passed pretty quickly after
that and your parents they were always
supportive with you acting and doing all
these things
um yeah i think so uh
again they were never in the industry
they had no
um
desire to be a part of the industry my
father worked in sort of
a manufacturing plant for aluminum and
torrents and he would make that drive
from sun valley to torrance every day
which was
crazy that's probably why he wanted to
get a divorce so he could live closer
but
my mom was you know i'm putting air
quotes up right now was my was my
manager until i was 18.
um
they were supportive in the way that
you're supportive of your kid doing
little league you know they they took me
to every game
they they rooted for me from
the sidelines told you they loved you
told you they support you told you they
loved you all that stuff
all that stuff i i i had nothing but
love for my parents we i heard that word
i love you every day wow um but i think
they also love the the the the monetary
aspect of being a child actor you know
we have to put some of it into a trust
but then others you know like wow we got
a car
and it has the license plate says for
mpg
oh thank you wait a minute i can't drive
it i can't drive it but thank you that's
my car yeah but they sucked a lot of
money away from you and i got to think
that
you know being on a show you probably
didn't get paid that much when you're
unsaved by the bell no
i think at the height of it again i
don't know the finances because i wasn't
involved at that time but i think at the
height of it we are getting paid maybe
five thousand a week for a show 5 000 a
week on a show now you think that's a
lot of money five thousand dollars a
week well you got agents and taxes and
you're walking out of there with two
grand a week on a show that's a hit show
that people are what kids are watching
all across the world
and you're making five thousand dollars
an episode i think when people assume
that when you're on tv they assume
you're making millions of dollars but
that's not where you're making your
bucks
no it's not where you're making their
bucks and then you think like well he
went to syndication
syndication for us i get syndication
checks i i i i giggle about it because
somebody had to print that on a chat but
it's like 13 cents
10 cents for you know
hundreds of shows being shown and it's
run its course
jesus so no i don't i don't make and
then you would think like oh well what
about merchandise well we got screwed
out of that too we don't get any money
through merchandise um
you know we don't we don't get much so
uh when you see our names as producers
on
the the peacock show it's a nice it's a
nice way for us to be a part of the show
again right and we we have always from
day one
um well i shouldn't say from day one i'd
say there was a period there where we
were all struggling to break free of
that you know this sort of stigma
attached to say by the bell but for the
most part we've we've all been very
positive
about our experiences with the with that
uh show it's also amazing that you've um
are you guys all still friends mostly
sure yeah i think so
and you know i read and you know of
course this is old news but it said you
actually dated three of your co-stars
but you're probably a kid when that
happened
yeah no i mean it all happened in the
span of the show none of us dated after
the show was cancelled
and so there was no bad blood about that
there was like who was the one that you
think you crushed on the hardest that
like it wasn't just dating like you
thought you were in love with
uh i i i mean i don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings so i i think i can
say that
i i probably didn't have the biggest
crush
on tiffany only because
tiffany and i had a different
relationship her and i were very
uh
we're almost like siblings in a way i
know that's hard for people who watch
the show it's like zach and kelly were
siblings but that's
we really had a closeness
that that's what that closeness
translated into and it's still to this
day she's probably the closest one that
i that
that i'm and i have a relationship with
now wow
yeah her and i you know probably
see each other
more than anyone else and
partly because i really like her husband
brady uh
he's just an amazing dude yeah and they
have good kids and you know i really
like her and i
yeah i like her family and stuff like i
like everyone's but tiffany and i always
had this closeness but it was it
translated into
being siblings and then when we kind of
dated it was just awkward it was weird
it didn't feel as great as like the
relationship we had before
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy i
can't tell you how many emails or texts
or messages i get
from people telling me that better help
is helping them
and i really love that i love
talking about something that works that
helps people that is a sponsor on the
podcast where we talk about mental
health
it's very important ryan's still with
better help i'm still a better help and
it's still
helping still helping help i like
hearing that you know people don't
always realize that physical symptoms
like headaches
teeth grinding even digestive issues can
be indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling sleeping too
little sleeping too much under eating
overeating stress shows up in all kinds
of ways and in a world that's telling
you to do more sleep less and grind all
the time here's your reminder to take
care of yourself to do less and maybe
try some therapy better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to ryan you like to see people i do i
think it helps i do too i like to see
the person i'm talking to but that's
just me if you don't feel like seeing a
face you don't have to you could also
text you could have you can do whatever
you want it's so much more affordable
than in-person therapy
trust me on that one
going in
in-person therapy is is so expensive
it's i'd say some cases it's triple
quadruple the cost of better health by
far
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours give it a try and see if
online therapy can help lower your
stress i believe it really can truly
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and inside of you listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash
in sign give therapy a shot
better help online therapy
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available 24
hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
uh you know i know this because i think
we've compared bruises or like you know
i know that you do the cycling and the
motocross and the auto racing and all
this [ __ ] you your passion is for racing
cars aren't you are you you're pretty
bruised up aren't you
yeah i love that quote his passion is
racing cars i think i said that back in
1996 when i was racing cars not anymore
you don't raise any cars anymore no i i
quickly realized that racing cars takes
a lot of money
uh
and and i i don't i have four kids i go
to private school so i i can't uh spend
my money on on airplanes and cars like i
used to
um
my background is racing motocross i
started racing when i was five i started
riding when i was three my brother is 16
years older than me
he's still in the industry he is
considered one of the greatest mechanics
of motocross history wow and uh he's the
one that kind of got me into it he has
four boys they were all pro at one point
in their career um
and then that sort of translated into
racing cars because that was a new thing
and then then when that dried up i went
into racing bicycles
um
and and uh did road biking and and did
pretty well i i i raced at the highest
level of amateurs um and traveled with a
team and just had a lot of fun
doing that um but yeah i'm pretty banged
up i mean you and i both have had
surgery on our neck yeah
do you have an artificial disc in your
neck do you have an artificial disc
no not yet are you fused
no no no i i had the first thing where
they just scope you i know you you have
you have the fuse yeah i've had in the
neck and then seven surgeries on my
lower back so yeah oh my god
why how did you just hockey and
degenerative discs and you know hey it's
embarrassing but i think it all started
at me working in a grocery store and uh
we were throwing boxes stocking boxes in
the back and everybody was throwing
these like boxes of del monte [ __ ]
fruit or whatever the hell they were and
i remember catching when i go oh man
that was weird and ever since that they
all started all the problems started so
really when i was about 17 i was 17 so i
had my first surgery when i was 18.
and it just never stopped they say once
you have cert one surgery you start
having a lot and that's what sort of
happened to me but you haven't had any
surgeries really
no i mean i my first major
injury happened when i was 16 i i
fractured my sternum my i tore ligaments
my neck my neck
was was
really bad and i i never got it fixed to
the point i should have
and and really
um
uh sort of
just been aware more of of my neck i
mean if there's one thing i could tell
the younger me was
just take some time off you know and and
get get it right because it will catch
up to you at some point and it caught up
for me after i i did pitch
um you know we were training
every single day
just
at a level 10 and above
um and then after that season i got my
first shoulder surgery and then the next
uh two years after that i got another
shoulder surgery and then the year after
that i got a neck surgery and those are
the only surgeries i've ever had
um a lot of stitches a lot of broken
things but never never any surgeries do
you want to race cars again
at some point i'd like to yeah i'd like
to but i also know that how expensive it
is so how is it how expensive is it
it's pretty i mean listen i i need to be
on on grey's anatomy like patrick
dempsey and then just basically uh use
that money to just supplement my uh
racing crate he's a great driver right
but he also made some great money and
and the more money you have the more
seat time you can get the better of a
driver you can be and the faster you'll
go so
um
and the more opportunities so racing
cars
is a is a pretty rich man and women
sport in my opinion how fast have you
gone what's the fastest speed you've
ever gone in the car
yeah i don't know because a lot of the
cars that i race they don't have
speedometers but i do remember being on
a motorcycle and i used to do road
racing on motorcycles and i was at
fontana and i was on a street bike it
was i think i got a loaner from yamaha
at the time or honda and the speedometer
was on there and i remember going down
the front straight away
and looking at the speedometer and going
that says 160. holy [ __ ] and then you
know going into the first turn but that
was the only time that i've ever had
like a speedometer on the thing i was
racing and i we were doing one sixth gun
in front straight jesus
motorcycles scare the [ __ ] out of me i
just won't get on one i just i just i
just like you know
you know why
i shouldn't be
no you should yeah it's not about you
driving it's about the guys that are
backing up or trying to get in the lane
they don't see you and that's that's the
danger right
i
discourage a lot of my friends from
getting motorcycles all the time and i'm
an advocate for motorcycles i'm an
advocate for motorcycle safety um
but i always discourage people like it
it's too dangerous especially here in
los angeles i mean i i see it all the
time you have so many
yeah
and they say well
you know i used to commute on a
motorcycle when i was doing nypd blue
for those four years i commuted when i
was in atlanta
um
every day all i had was a motorcycle
there when i was there for six months
doing the passage um i feel safer on
freeways oddly enough because you only
have to really worry about two
directions what's coming at you and
possibly what's coming behind you but
you're you're going so fast hopefully
that you're you'll stay out of trouble
which is kind of weird to say right um
but on a street man it's four directions
that you have to worry about what's
coming at you from the sides from behind
you
just a lot and then if you go like and i
never do this but a lot of guys like to
go to the mulholland and do the roads
and
yeah that's just too [ __ ] dangerous
for me it's like if there's a pebble or
a debris in the corner and i'm going
through their
cyclist or a car
jumps the yellow line
[ __ ] man you're done you're done
that easily that quickly too
you know you you said once you always
have a feeling that you're losing
everything so you're a real saver is
that still true that you always feel
like [ __ ] i'm not gonna have enough
money i'm not gonna what is that where
does that come from uh i don't know i
mean i i i we grew up
squarely middle class but i guess i
always felt like we were kind of below
middle class
because
the kids that i went to school with
i thought that they they had a better
lifestyle and you know
than i did and again like i said i
always looked up towards the mulholland
the greenness and that part of the
valley compared to where we were
i know um my parents
you know they they work their asses off
they had great work ethic um
i
i've i've i thought my i had a career
going until
you know the end of stay by the bell and
i thought
you know i'm in this is this is my
this is my job and i i i'm gonna make a
living and then i didn't work for about
two years and
it was it was scary and and didn't have
an income and it's not like you know i i
could go and get a job
waiting tables because a i was right
still recognizable b my ego
um so you know i was like detailing cars
with my cousin
uh to try to make a try to make a living
at certain things and it's not not that
i'm afraid of work because i love
working i love to work with my hands i
love to i love manual labor um
and i i
i really do um but the ego it was the
ego really wasn't it it was the ego it
was the ego as i was like a [ __ ] dude
i can't even walk into a mall without
people recognizing me but i i'm i'm
fighting to get a job like what am i
going to do what is just yeah
it was a bad position to be in and how
long did it take you before you started
making money again and you were all
right
uh well the show wrapped in 94 when we
did the college years and i think 96 is
when i started working again i got a i
got a tv movie for nbc of all places
because we were always on nbc and i got
a nbc movie that i auditioned for um it
wasn't an offer and then
after that things started happening
again but
i don't know man you know it's like i i
think that
everything is
everything is dispensable in a way you
know
nothing is
in my eyes forever
and i just want to make sure that i
appreciate everything that i have in my
life and
not take it for granted you know my my
marriage my kids
my health yeah um you know there's a
point in your life where you just
realize holy [ __ ] it's all limited right
like it's
it's it's not it's it's not we're not
gonna be here forever
yeah that's for sure i think that's true
the older you get you start to think
about
wow we're all expendable we're all going
to the same place how many years do i
actually have left and what do i really
love what do i really want to who do i
really want to spend my time with and
these
however many years you have you start to
think more about those things
yeah i when i when i was going through
the divorce my my
therapist at the time
he basically said uh you know a lot of
people think life is short he goes but
it's not it's long life is long and i
was 36 when i when i was going through
this and he said you've only been living
your life for about 18 years you know
when you when you be when you turned 18
you became an adult you started living
your life because you have another 50
plus years ahead of you that are all
yours you can make
you can it's your decisions
uh and he says so
think about that like
the amount of time it took me to get to
36 and that felt like a lifetime and it
goes but you you haven't even
you have
50 years of that left yeah
wow what do you think you would have
done
if you didn't act
uh
i don't know i i've always been in sport
i i think like every other kid i wanted
to be in the super bowl and you know i
have memories of watching uh the 49ers
in the super bowl watching montana rice
clark you know
and clark and that catch and just
you know having a football in the living
room and just diving on the floor and
having
dreams of doing that uh one day and yeah
probably i want to do something in sport
i always wanted to do you still get
sensitive are you sensitive to
you know like being on a show and then
it gets canceled because lord knows
we've all been on shows and they get
cancelled are you one of those that
you're just like when somebody goes oh
they're gonna you're gonna get picked up
right are you usually like
not even going there i no it's not as as
far as i'm concerned this is probably it
what's your mentality with all that yeah
um
it's funny that you bring this up
because my wife um
you know she just goes can't you ever be
happy
when you know it's like
if if if i if i get a show for instance
right and it's like it
your show gets picked up i'm like yeah
but big it has to
air and then after it airs it has to get
um you know the certain rating and after
the first year we got to get a second
here and after that we have to get into
syndication there's always something
always and she goes yeah but just be
happy for what it is i go but
i don't know if i can't anymore because
we've been in this business for oh i
mean
i've been in for over 30 years when did
you get your side card uh probably when
i was uh
23 24. so 25 years
yeah i got my card in 84.
wow
and a lot has happened i mean i've had a
lot of ups and downs um
but you just you know like
i i
you you take a show and and like pitch
for instance i auditioned for that i
fought for it um i i worked my ass off
to be that character some of the
greatest material i'd ever i ever got
um you know some of the best uh
compliments i ever had in my life from
people my peers and critics and things
like that
and it doesn't go and it's dan fogelman
dan fulgman this is us and pitch those
are these two shows out here this is us
takes off and becomes what it is
and pitch
you know shits the bed and dives then
you go to the passage again we get you
know a great material and great ip and
great people and
uh last year then you go to a mix dish
and you're on mix issue you're like oh
my god well i can retire off of this i'm
working with kenya barris and all the
people from blackish and look at the run
blackish's had
you know and the the the pedigree that
you're working with and you're like okay
i'm done and then it goes a season and a
half and it's done
see nothing nothing is a guarantee
nothing is a guarantee
so at this point do you think you have
pretty [ __ ] thick skin where you're
like you know like you know hey bring it
to me i don't have any expectations do
you think now like your wife said you're
gonna enjoy the moment more or you still
can't do that no i don't think i can i i
still care too much i really do i really
care about
i really care about the work and i care
about the people and uh it's a tough
business for for people who really give
a [ __ ] i always think that the left the
less [ __ ] i gave the easier this
business would be for me right i mean if
you just were like i [ __ ] care i i
just worry about myself i just worry
about myself and
you know whatever comes comes i've never
been that way my life i've always
thought of my family first and then my
my you know
the people around me and
um
yeah i think i should give less [ __ ]
that's gonna be my my uh my resolution
for 2022. give less [ __ ]
give less bucks god it would be so nice
i think about it all the time i just
want to care less just if i could just
care less i'll be better off and you try
but it's just like i think that's where
passion comes in it's like you're so
passionate that's it's hard to give
no [ __ ]
you know what i mean
you're just so passionate about
something you want something to work and
it doesn't how do you just go oh yeah
[ __ ] it i don't give a [ __ ]
you give a [ __ ] because you care because
you're passionate you know what i mean
yeah but then you i mean you see it in
our business there's a lot of people
that don't give [ __ ] and man are they
successful yeah i know [ __ ] [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
hey this is called [ __ ] talking with
mark paul gossler now is gosselar
you know that joe buck uh joe buck i
always [ __ ] it up
joe buck he [ __ ] it up well he didn't
[ __ ] up but he did say gosselwar
and uh this is when i was on fox and he
had to say my name during the gossel
gosselaar
and uh
he got [ __ ] for saying that like he hit
[ __ ] for saying anything
so he says
gosselaar and then people start going
dude you're such a douchebag it's
gossler and he's like oh my god i [ __ ]
up mark paul's name
so
he calls to apologize to me what and
yeah yeah he calls to apologize to me
and i play the game i'm like dude what
the [ __ ]
how did you not know my name is mark
paul gosliner not gossip like why would
you do that and he felt he was mortified
and uh then you know
i kind of let him off the hook and told
him i was a prank and whatever and um
became friends but it it the the correct
pronunciation is probably gosselaar
because that's the closest to how we say
it in dutch which is wholesaling
but
yeah
there you go all right you might be uh
you might be dutch all right um but we
just i just say mark paul gossler
g-o-s-s-l-e-r it's the american version
i love that joe buck called you up to
apologize for mispronouncing your name
that is a sweet [ __ ] thing to do
he's a sweet man
and and i don't care what anybody says i
like the dude and i think he does a
really good job
yeah i do too all right this is called
[ __ ] talking with mark paul gossler this
is a these are my patrons
they give back to the podcast they care
about it they love it they get to ask
them questions so this is you know you
can answer them however you want some of
them might be redundant because we might
have talked about it but here we go lisa
h obviously i grew up watching you with
zach morris but my question is about a
more recent role i love the show mixtish
so disappointed when it was canceled do
you feel there were more stories to be
told and what episode was your favorite
i feel there were more stories to be
told i was always looking forward to the
day i think the show started in 88
that's that's when uh that's when the
era that we were in
um
and i was hoping that we'd get to the
90s because then they could watch say by
the belt
uh yeah and i i thought that was kind of
that would have been kind of fun
actually that show is 86
yeah [ __ ] i can't remember man see this
is this is my problem
um
that's what happens but yeah it was
my favorite episode oh man i i don't
remember i mean i i can't remember what
episode was fun i had
i had a lot of fun on that show with
with those actors um
good good group tika sumter great
actress
uh
yeah i just
the whole experience was good good fun
dave p what convinced you to return to
save by the bell
uh what convinced me to return say it
say it say money just be [ __ ] money
no money money was good i mean money
money was good uh i'm working with tracy
wakefield and um and
i had a meeting with her before she
started writing and she pitched me the
idea
and i thought it was brilliant and then
when i saw it on the page i was like
holy [ __ ] she she did it she cracked it
and then uh yeah money and and and
the fact that i get to put my name on as
a producer those are all good things
leanne why do you think saved by the
bell still resonates with such a younger
audience
it's interesting i i just had a friend
of me send me a video of his daughters
and i believe they're under 10
and uh i sent the video back
uh because their very favorite character
is zack morris and they're they were
watching but i have no idea
um why the show still resonates my my
kids are watching
other things like the thundermans or
something like that on on nickelodeon i
don't know is that is that a thing i
remember under thundercats
i remember the thundercats but this is
like a live adventure
but it's it's like this tv show where
the the family it's kind of kind of like
the incredibles they all have superhero
uh super abilities super powers oh wow
um and uh i don't know if it's on
nickelodeon or or what my kids watch
that um
and and so i'm always i'm always
surprised because there's some really
fun shows out there but people then find
save by the bell and it still feels
current and relevant to them i don't
know maybe it's the simplicity it's the
time it's the just you you care about
these guys uh
i don't know there's a lot to it i mean
you i mean you tell me but i think you
know it was just easy to watch you just
threw it on and you just had a laugh or
you just you know oh you like the girl
or oh i want to be the cool guy or i
want a guy you know i'm the geek
you know it's sort of man i don't know i
don't know because they're saved by the
bell the new class there's uh
hanging uh hang time there's california
dreams all these shows and for some
reason people
pick out saved by the bell yeah
david h you've been in some amazing
shows worked with some amazing people
who do you think has been your biggest
mentor and who have you remained friends
with through the years
my biggest mentor was dennis franz um
and and that whole crew uh stephen black
dennis franz mark tinker um dennis franz
actually you got you became close with
and you actually hung out with a lot
yeah yeah he he was hired from the
business once once uh nypd blue was over
that was it he was done he came to see
me do a play in 2010 or 2009 he came to
see me do a play in new york um and i
asked him at that point we went out for
dinner afterwards and i said you don't
miss it and he goes no not really
because he was so [ __ ] good he he is
just an amazing actor and he kind of
just gave it up
uh
yeah and just walked away i mean he said
he made it i don't
you made a [ __ ] ton of money i guess
this
felt i don't know what he felt to be
honest i mean it gets don't you think it
gets old do you ever think about god i'd
like to have enough money or i'd like to
just walk away or do you really just
like it so much that you want to keep
doing it to your old and gray or do you
kind of feel like god i'd like to be
done with this [ __ ]
there's part of me that would like to be
done with the grind right i i would love
to have dennis franz money
and basically live you know the life
that i want to live
but there's part of me that there's the
creative side of me right where i would
still want to be a part of some creative
process whether that's working with
uh
directors or producers or what i don't
know if i necessarily need to be in
front of the camera i don't
i i get just as much joy being behind
the camera that i do in the front so but
i do like to create i do like to i like
the process i like i like collaborating
camaraderie
yeah uh michelle cage you keep any cool
[ __ ] from saved by the bell
i wish i did i talked about this on the
podcast um
i i i wasn't sentimental at all you know
being a 16 year old
uh not i wasn't sentimental with
anything
uh my health you know girlfriends
whatever um i didn't start becoming
sentimental until uh nypd blew and when
that wrapped i was close to 31 and when
that wrapped um i took my fake gun i
took my badge i took my notepad i took
a lamp that was sitting on sip with his
desk i took whatever the [ __ ] wasn't
bolted down
um that's it but from save by the bell i
have nothing and as i watch the shows i
go [ __ ] i wish i would have taken that
like there was this episode where we had
these screech masks i was like [ __ ] wish
i had that oh man yeah
i saved a lot of these
shirts i stole a lot of [ __ ] oh yeah i
stole a lot of [ __ ] from the set
jackets lex white president suits uh
the jacket where i played zod this
jacket they made for me
um
uh a mask that i wore when my character
splits in half which is up there
onyx uh scripts got [ __ ] signed i just
was like i always felt like this is
gonna be my last show every show i ever
did i always thought they're gonna
figure me out you know i think a lot of
actors think that but i thought just you
know i'm gonna get autographs and if i
go broke i'll just sell this [ __ ]
do you have a problem do you have a
problem asking people progress no if you
if you were here right now if you came
over you'd see i have a room full of uh
posters autographed horror movies i got
the whole cast signed aliens my thing by
kurt russell signed the thing poster an
escape from new york my fright night
poster from the director tom holland
evil dead bruce campbell
kiefer sutherland and jason patrick
signed my lost boys poster uh i just i
don't give a [ __ ] man i just i love it i
was a collector i
went to cons conventions before i was an
actor or made it or anything and i just
still feel like that kid so yeah i don't
give a [ __ ]
but i know most people do most people
are like i don't ask for autographs
that's weird dude
yeah i don't know i i i don't have
i mean i'm trying to think if i have
autographs i
not that i i think i have a few jerseys
down stairs
you have joe montana no i i have a
football from him i did ask him for see
this is the thing people will [ __ ] it up
for you right i i was at a um
i think it was a madden event you know
and when when they used to like ask
celebrities to come out we were doing
like a flag football game for matt yeah
and it was down and and um
i got uh
i got montana's autograph and i asked
for another guys
um i'm not gonna name his name but he
gave me the dirtiest [ __ ] look when i
got it
and i was like man i don't i didn't want
to do this to begin with and now you're
giving me making me feel bad wow [ __ ]
i'm decided i mean i can't do it
i don't think i don't think i've done it
since oh man i did that with uh mike
tyson mike tyson was on this show called
breaking and he was just a guest star
and i had some scenes with him and i go
and i i said [ __ ] for the cast i bought
a whole bunch of boxing gloves like six
of them or seven of them and i go i came
in this trailer i go hey would you sign
i go beforehand i go would you mind
signing a glove he goes no absolutely
man yeah i'll sign your glove i'll sign
the boxing glove for you and i went into
his uh trailer and i had he goes what
the what the [ __ ] is this man
i go oh it's just for the cast he goes
oh [ __ ] man i just thought i thought i
was signing for just you man i go oh oh
you can my bad i just thought he goes no
that's fine man that's fine but i could
tell he was upset and i was like [ __ ]
dude and then i thought he gives a [ __ ]
i'll never see him again [ __ ] it i just
got six obviously no no you know why
he's probably thinking back look dude i
give you a [ __ ] i give you a morsel
and you ask for the whole body
he's right though he's right i was a
dick you're right i just thought about
it i'm a dick but i still don't but
you're you're welcome
cast i'm unappreciative of [ __ ]
uh he was uh
he was on on
franklin bash as well
and um
uh brecken
had a funny little face to face with him
uh he was he it was right after he did
this um you know the whole thing with
the with the broadway thing yeah and it
was like everybody was so impressed with
how he did and so that's what he was
supposed to play like this refined
man who gave up violence
and um
the line like
long story short brecken's supposed to
hit him and he's supposed to be like why
would you do that i i i you know i'm i'm
i'm just
you know i'm a broadway guy now kind of
thing but he took it the other way no
one gave him any direction so when
brecken does his fake punched and and
you know hits him he gets in brecken's
face as full
mike tyson like the guy that you fear
he's like why the [ __ ] would you do that
like all of us
back the [ __ ] up and i was like whoa
this guy is going to attack brecken
and then after that take was over the
director's like that was great mike uh
we're gonna go in a different direction
we're gonna we're gonna you know it's
actually the opposite of that you're
just you're you're you're you're the guy
on broadway you know that that guy
that's the guy we want he's like oh okay
okay okay yeah i got that wrong and he
did it it was great
man he's he's he's still so freaking
intense oh my god uh maya p you've been
working constantly for 40 years nearly
40 years what advice would you give
someone on how to maintain longevity in
the business
uh
man um don't take it personally
i guess that's the hardest thing you
just said but you're right
the chief the chief says what's your
fondest story or memory with screech
dustin diamond
you know we we were close when we were
doing the show and then all of us went
our own way so
there were many many years where we
weren't in each other's lives um but i
just remember
laughing a lot with dustin he was the
goofiest [ __ ] you ever could
get
in the same room with he made these
choices that were just the choices that
only he could make on on the screen he
was really good he was a very talented
actor
um at a very young age um but we we had
a lot of good times and uh just remember
a lot of laughter with him and playing
video games i remember playing a lot of
video games with the guy too and his dad
would just sit in his room and he had
like a neo geo
uh back when that was like the premiere
gaming platform
and uh he was the coolest kid geo
my god i mean were was it tough when you
heard about the loss did you feel like
you just got kind of
it was just shocking to you were you
were you shocked or did you know about
it
i was totally shocked because a year
before i had seen him at a comic-con and
we were next to each other and
you know
he never said a word about his health
and then to find out that he died so
quickly um without any of us really
knowing what was going on that that was
shocking and really sad that he didn't
he he didn't uh
you know connect with us a little bit
more before his passing um i don't i
don't think it's his fault i just think
that maybe he thought things were going
to be better or um
[Music]
yeah exactly but
it was shocking it was very sad and and
uh
i mean jesus christ he was only 42 or so
that's unbelievable
do you last last question you know we
didn't really talk about it but with all
the work and all the success you've had
and all the shows you've done did you
ever have to deal did you ever do i
always ask the guest did you ever deal
with uh any anxiety did you do you still
deal with anxiety is it something that's
been a part of you or something that you
look you're looking to be like of course
what the [ __ ] are you talking about [ __ ]
dude i haven't i have anxiety like i i
had anxiety coming on your show i have
anxiety like i do too minutes before i
come on i swear to you i have anxiety
like i'm riddled with anxiety me too um
it just it just
i i don't i don't do anything
other than punish myself um with sport
and working out
thankfully i don't abuse
alcohol or drugs i don't uh i'm not
reliant on any sort of substance
to get me through my anxiety i try to
work on it by
um making myself a better human being
and
and
finding things that will you know make
me better i
got into cold exposure last year and uh
that's helping with anxiety and um
you know there's certain things that i'm
uh like natural supplements that i take
uh trying to try to understand myself
um
i know i'm being very vague but no this
helps i think a lot of people especially
that listen you know hearing from like
someone like yourself that you know you
deal with anxiety they're like they're
probably shocked you know and it just it
helps normalize that and also you know
you're saying exercise helps you
obviously right you said cold therapy
what's cold therapy or cold uh what is
that exposure exposure um i i did a i
did a film with ryan quanton and before
that i knew nothing about cold exposure
he he basically goes into the ocean
every morning and every night and just
like no matter how cold it is and i was
so fascinated with that there's a lot of
meditating i don't have the capacity to
meditate as much as i'd like to or at
all it's just like if i have 10 minutes
i'd rather punish myself with jiu jitsu
or you know hitting a bag or weights or
you know doing a crossfit routine um
but i'm learning to really
put a lot of effort into recovery and
whether that's
you know getting enough sleep
and um
eating better not that i ate like [ __ ]
but eating more towards
um
eating enough for me uh in a way and
that doesn't mean like consumption and
and
eating
to my body yeah well said well said well
this has been a real treat man i i
appreciate you coming on here and being
so open and candid you never know with
guests and you were really just
forthcoming you are you're just like you
know because i read somewhere you're you
know you are you're a shy guy you're a
private guy and when i've met you you
just you're always humble and sweet and
you just never know i'm like well this
could be a really quick interview or you
know and it was uh it was uh it was a
lot of fun for me i think i think the
reason why i'll tend to be shy is
because i'm worried about what what can
happen with my words and i'm sure you
know in this day and age now you say one
[ __ ] thing yeah and it just like
people take a snippet of it and it
again because i care so much
it they take it and i go [ __ ]
that's not what i learned that just
happened with a guest uh you know i had
jensen ackles on and um you know
he i heard that one i heard what he said
he didn't and if you listen to it it's
like i love her she's like a sister but
she was horrible but it wasn't it was
almost joking but you know the way they
put it out there is horrible to work
with and it just exploded and went viral
exploding i texted and he was like he's
like dude you know i don't give a [ __ ]
what can you do it's like you know it's
like
we need the jensen echoes diet that's
the diet we need we need that diet yeah
zero [ __ ] yeah it's like you know
zero sugar monster energy drink and zero
[ __ ] zero [ __ ]
that's that's my resolution zero [ __ ]
ryan ryan's my engineer over there yeah
good luck good luck how long that you
break that resolution uh you have a
better chance of being dry for the
entire 2022. well dude let's get
together sometime i'd love to see when
all this shit's
done and we could just get together for
a
soda or some [ __ ]
soda a beer whatever we'll get together
for whatever i don't know you don't even
make soda anymore i don't know do they
i don't even one of my new year's
resolutions was to get done with soda no
more sodas
so we'll do something else what are you
are you a drinker do you drink
yeah well i'd like to have a dram every
night of scotch
my wife is scottish even before we were
together i was always into having scotch
uh love scotch um
try not to do that
every night but it's pretty hard not to
um but do you do any sport besides i
mean i knew you were doing softball and
stuff like that uh you know i do the the
softball with friends and stuff i'm you
know i play a little tennis here and
there a little golf
um and i'm going to start playing hockey
again i think you know recreationally oh
yeah you know i just got to be careful
but yeah i just i miss it so much that i
got to get back on the ice
are you are you with the uh guys yeah i
still play down there at the uh sports
center toyota sports center now
wait is that still elsa got another
segundo yeah so uh i haven't played like
seven months but
yeah i'm gonna do it why don't you try
it's been a while
well when was the last time you played
eight months ago
oh well [ __ ] yeah i played last time i
played was 2016.
big deal you go out one you look like
[ __ ] the next time you come out you look
like less [ __ ] and you just keep getting
better
all right you give me the invite for
those guys and i'll see if i can make it
work i will i really will card pull
together
together
that's a long-ass drive too that's a
good 45-minute drive but when you've got
some hauling oats in the car you're good
to go
[Laughter]
good to see you dude i love this man i
appreciate it and i'll send i'll let you
know when it's coming out sounds good
buddy i appreciate it thanks for having
me on
[Music]
i i was uh you know i was tad nervous
he's a big get well i i thought you know
he was a great guest but i was worried
that you know as going to want to talk
about it maybe he doesn't even want to
talk about saved by the bell maybe he
doesn't want to talk about he talked
about everything what i brought up did
you date when you dated these guys or
what you were who was your friend that
he he opened up yep i like that man so
uh i think you could appreciate that i
hope uh you enjoyed the podcast
i know i did
i'm reminding you to join patreon if you
want to uh get back to the podcast and
keep it going go to patreon.com inside
of you
support us um also inside of you online
store to get cool merch like scripts
marvel scripts and tumblers from inside
of you i think i have there's so much
great stuff go the inside of you online
store and also uh my band sunspin we're
recording a new album go to sunspin.com
and you could uh book a book the band
for a zoom um i'm also on the cameo you
know who got me in the cameo who shawn
aston really yeah
sean aston got me in the cameo and
people really like the cameo they like
getting birthday messages and things and
i have a lot of fun with it i really
have a lot of fun with it i'll sing to
people i'll
joke with people i'll you know
i'll do whatever
i'm a monkey
dance dance monkey dance
uh but uh look i appreciate you guys
choosing this podcast
every week or at least maybe just this
week if you're here but if you enjoyed
it maybe you'll stick around and listen
to other guests we get deep and it's not
like uh it's it's unlike a lot of other
podcasts where they just talk about
fluff and actory stuff we i try to get a
little deep and we find out things that
you you know you as a
listener can relate to and you know
whether it's anxiety or mental health
issues or
just facing adversity it's it's
something that i like to dive into when
the guests are
open and willing to do so
uh it's this time
to
list off all the wonderful patrons
that have made this show possible thank
you couldn't do it without you i've said
it before join patreon go to patreon.com
but these are the top tier
nancy
d leah
yeah
what what
yes correct sarah
v little lisa you kiko jill e brian h
nico p robert c
p yes jason w kristen k allison l raj c
joshua d cj p jennifer and stacy l jen s
jamal f janelle b kimberly
e mike
uh
d
e correct eldon
supremo
99 more santiago m correct chad d
no who you no
close to you chad w w is that what you
said yes i said d belu w will i'm gonna
give you that leanne
uh p janine r maya p mattie
n chris
h dave h spider-man chase sheila g brad
d rey h tabitha t tom n liliana a talia
am correct i'm gonna give you that betsy
r no
oh miss betsy betsy d that's correct
betsy d
chad
is this not chad d this is gonna rhyme
chad
l andra
l
rochelle rochelle oh rochelle marion meg
k trav l dan n big stevie w god you know
ryan just nailed
a ton a [ __ ] ton in order that is
surprisingly amazing big stevie w angel
m rhiannon c corey k super sam dev next
to michelle a jeremy c andy t cody r
gavinator david c john b brandy d yvore
camille s the c
joey m willie f david h adelaide n omar
i lena n design otg eugene and leah
hello chris p nikki g corey patricia
heather
jake b james b bobbitt
abel f joshua b able i just sent you
stuff i just sent you from patreon you
know you're in the top tier so you get
merch i just remember sending you a box
of merch i'll just say that i remember
saying abel
joshua b tony g sean r megan t mel s
orlando c john b caroline r darren b
robbie e
robbie paul c christine s s
sarah s eric h spring and jennifer r
couldn't do the podcast without you guys
uh i thank you from the bottom of my
heart
um
another week we just keep going we just
keep going with podcasts it's uh you
know
it's nice because now we're going to get
like the rest of this week off after we
do our ad stay so ryan and i will have
this week and next week off but you
won't because we'll have podcasts edited
and ready for you so don't worry the
podcast must go on but i know that i'm
getting a little bit of a break and so
are you good and that would be nice
won't it yeah it's nice to get a little
two-week break yeah yeah and then we'll
come back and we'll fire away um don't
you think
well i can't say it but you know there
is a big surprise coming and uh you know
i can't wait to share it with you once
we can share it um you'll be the first
ones on this podcast to when i announce
it to hear it um something good is
coming so
from myself here in the hollywood hills
of california i'm michael rosenbaum i'm
bryan tears ryan tanz a little wave to
the camera we love you and most
importantly ryan white
uh be good to each other and be good
uh humans and be good
to
to
yourself oh yes i think that's the most
important thing i mean obviously be good
to others this is important you're
pointing at you as like be good to you
good good to michael america
but uh be good yourselves enjoy your
week enjoy your life you only get one as
far as we know so just make the most of
it have fun
live a little all right we'll see you
next week
[Music]